al completarse 12 años de la guerra
civil miles de sirios salieron a las
calles de ibliff la única zona que sigue
bajo el control de la oposición para
seguir pidiendo la salida del presidente
bashara la Sad y para conmemorar aquel
15 de marzo de 2011 cuando una masiva
manifestación sacudió Damasco la capital
del país
nosotros participamos en el inicio de la
Revolución y estamos aquí hoy con motivo
del aniversario 12 para llevar al mundo
entero el mensaje de que mantenemos las
demandas que motivaron nuestro
movimiento y para dar a conocer al mundo
la opresión que hemos enfrentado
en el marco de la primavera árabe una
bola de protestas iniciada en túnez y
Egipto motivó grandes cambios en la
región controlados por los gobiernos
autoritarios incluidos Siria desde
entonces al menos 613.000 personas han
muerto más de 2.1 millones de personas
han resultado heridas y la mitad de la
población del país que antes de la
guerra era de 23 millones ha quedado
desplazada según el observatorio sirio
de Derechos Humanos el conflicto se ha
prolongado con la intervención
internacional y el país ha quedado
dividido principalmente en cuatro partes
el régimen sirio apoyado por Rusia las
fuerzas kurdas movidas por Estados
Unidos la oposición al régimen y el
autodenominado estado islámico y aunque
han intentado mesas de diálogo para
solucionar esta guerra no se ha logrado
ningún acuerdo concreto
en cuanto a los acuerdos políticos que
se ponen sobre la mesa no me comprometo
con un criminal que me dejó
discapacitado mucha gente aquí está de
acuerdo en que no podemos reconciliarnos
con un criminal que nos bombardea
Mientras tanto el conflicto se mantiene
latente el cual parece estar estancado y
lejos de un cambio afectando
principalmente a civiles inocentes